we want to get to news out of California
which is facing a critical fire danger
this morning at least a half dozen
wildfires are burning across the state
at this hour and forecasters say high
winds and low humidity are increasing
the risk those conditions prompted the
state's largest power utility that's
PG&E to shut off electricity to more
than 700,000 customers Jonathan
Vigliotti is in Sonoma Jonathan doesn't
sound good how is it affecting people
living there yeah very hard as you can
imagine a lot of people still without
power and it could last for days one
expert telling us that the state could
lose in total about two and a half
billion dollars that's billion with a be
some of the hardest hit areas
downtown's like here in Sonoma the power
was cut yesterday morning as the high
wind started to pick up some people
telling us they only got a few hours
notice before the lights were cut the
high winds that fueled wildfires late
Wednesday continued overnight the
dangerous mix of swaying trees and power
lines would increase the Wildfire threat
if the power wasn't already cut Ron
Blasingame is coping with the blackout I
should have bought a generator those are
gone yeah they're gone nobody has those
he says Pacific Gas and Electric hasn't
been doing its job to keep its
infrastructure safe they haven't cleared
the brush from their lines but they want
to pay dividends and give the executives
money it's public utility yeah we're
paying for that what's your message to
PG&E do your job protect the public
many waited in long lines to fill their
gas tanks before the pumps lost
electricity and shut down Barry
Freeman's home improvement store lost
power but managed to stay open
guiding customers by flashlights to buy
among other things flashlights a lot of
people coming in here is it fair to say
some of them were caught off-guard by
this oh for sure unfortunately we've run
out of some of those products that they
need Debbie Medina relies on her CPAP
and oxygen generators to stay alive her
condition prevents her from getting to
community centers what are you gonna do
with people like myself because I know
I'm not the only one a lot of people say
they feel like they are being punished
for what they're calling PG and E's
failures and listen this is gonna be a
long-term problem to put this in
perspective PG&E says it could cause as
much as 110 billion dollars to place all
of the overhead lines underground some
of the more pressing concerns though as
simple as communications a lot of people
coming up to us asking to charge their
cell phones using our generators Anthony
Jonathan thank you